my name is Dustin Kirkland I'm a product
manager at Google and I'm here with Maya
catcher offski also a product manager at
Google and she knows everything about
security I certainly don't know
everything about security enough enough
that we're gonna talk about security
osgood
especially the security vulnerability
space around kubernetes what what
interesting vulnerabilities have you
seen recently yeah in the last couple of
months we've had a couple of interesting
bombs so you know let's look at 2019
there was a run see vulnerability
earlier this year which was effectively
a container escape and then more
recently the Alpine images had a newer
versions have a route default password
which which is kind of scary scary yeah
what was that password just so we know
it was just null I think it was no yeah
just terrifying
and then obviously we've also had some
additional speculative execution
vulnerabilities that have been announced
so lots of things affecting the kernel
and OSS and the community space 3
something yeah and what do we what are
we learning are we learning anything
from this trying to make kubernetes in
our space better I think I think when
they grew people realize is that Corona
is actually really good at managing
patches and vulnerabilities right
kubernetes has a product security team
that handles cribben any specific phones
and then probably your cloud provider is
is managing a lot of that stuff for you
on GCP we we manage two patches for you
and you can check out the security
bulletins to see how you've been patched
but we're also seeing as a lot of
interest from security researchers in
the space and seeing what's going on and
you know can they exploit these
vulnerabilities and in live environments
so the the runs Yvonne had no proofs of
concept available within a matter of
days and the quickly were patches
available patches were available so it
was embargo and AD announcement the
patches were elegant the and the Alpine
images you know a security researcher
recently found out that 20% of them a
20% of the top docker hub images were
using the null password which is which
is absolutely terrifying and then so
that's kubernetes itself what about the
applications inside of kubernetes how
are we how are we approaching this in a
modern containerized software world that
I don't know it hopefully is a little
bit better than prior generations of
software yeah that's a good point I
think people just say think of like
attacks on containers as being only one
category you can split it up between
attacks on the infrastructure like
towards the Khronos API server
versus attacks on applications which
just happen to be running in containers
right and so for applications that
happen to be running in containers we're
not seeing attacks in a while that are
significantly different or significantly
more common than you would see in any
other environment what's what's
happening is people are looking
attackers are lazy right they're looking
for vulnerabilities that have been
unpatched for years and seeing if they
can exploit those and they don't they
don't seem to care whether or not it's a
it's a containerized application hmm
would it be fair to say that that modern
C ICD and the way we use that in in
kubernetes should be helping our ability
to patch safely and reliably it should
right if you think about a container
you're you're not patching a live
container you're actually patching a
container that's it's in a right image
it's it's in a registry and then
rebuilding and redeploying that that
container so patching it becomes as easy
for you to implement as your typical
your normal rollout process or you can
actually patch something with the same
canarian testing deployment all those
tools that you would use anyways and
make it much safer than you would
otherwise what that should mean in
theory although not always in practice
is that you should be able to patch more
often and patch more easily than you
would have been able to do before
yeah and do you think we're seeing that
yet I think we are yeah you know here
are some customers who are tearing down
their entire environment and redeploying
at every X hours X days for sure right
gke and security what are some of the
things we're doing to push the envelope
in that space sure so at our recent next
conference Google Cloud announced a
couple things we have binary
authorization which is our way of
enforcing that containers meet certain
requirements before they get deployed to
production GC our vulnerability scanning
this is kind of really we were just
talking about around patching things
before they end up in production so you
actually can apply apply certain patches
lets you scan images in your repository
for known vulnerabilities and we just
announced GK sandbox in beta which is
using Google's G visor technology to
help you isolate untrusted code in your
environment in in multi-tenant
environments and of course working on
more but I don't have anything to share
right right away all right Maya thank
you very much thank you so much
[Music]
you